all right a brutal day for big Tech
Executives on Capitol Hill as they
testified before the Senate Judiciary
Committee at a hearing on child safety
with an audience of parents that lost
children to the many horrors of social
media lawmakers they did not hold back
with their questions and they had
particularly harsh words for meta CEO
and that would be Mark Zuckerberg take a
look at this Mr Zuckerberg you and the
companies before us I know you don't
mean it to be so but you have blood on
your hands you have a
product you have a
product that's killing people Senator my
understanding is that we don't allow
sexually explicit content on on the
service for people of any age um the the
um how is that going uh you know are are
uh these results may contain images of
child sexual abuse and then you gave
users two
choices get
resources
or see results
anyway Mr Zuckerberg what the hell were
you thinking in what sane universe is
there a link for C results anyway well
because we might be wrong let me ask you
this there's families of victims here
today have you apologized to the victims
I would you like to do so now well
they're here you're on National
Television would you like now to
apologize to the victims who have been
harmed by your product show them the
pictures would you like to apologize for
what you've done to these good
people I'm
sorry terrible no one should have to go
through the things that your families
have have suffered and this is why we
invested so much and are going to
continue doing industry Le efforts to uh
to make sure that no one has to go
through the types of things that your
families can
suffer here with more on today's hearing
is Missouri Senator John J Holly Senator
good to see you um there are very
specific scams and and ways to entrap
young people I don't think everybody in
America is fully aware of this
sextortion being one of them uh can you
explain how dangerous this is and what
is out there and the impact it's having
on kids so everyone really gets
this oh it's it's having an incredible
impact on kids Sean and I mean teenagers
listen I'm the father of three kids none
of them are teenagers yet thank goodness
but if you're a teen I mean here's some
stats Young Girls teenage girls between
the ages of 13 and 15 on Instagram 37%
of them saw nudity on the platform
unwanted sent to their accounts within
the first seven days of being on the
platform 25% of them within 7even days
Sean were propositioned sexually by an
adult man I mean just think about this
these are girls between the ages of 13
and 15 that data by the way comes from
Facebook that's their own internal data
this is a company that has profited off
of the exploitation of kids the
exploitation of minors and now it's time
for them to pay up they need to set up a
victim's compensation fund they need to
pay these people and you know what the
families ought to be able to sue them it
was pretty powerful moment that you got
Zuckerberg to stand up I wouldn't really
call it maybe the most sincere apology
um and that's why we continue to do more
to to be the best at what we do Etc how
is it possible or is it even possible
that he doesn't know this is going on
there's no way that they don't know and
there's no way that they haven't known
for a long time uh your committee has
been all over them for a long time on
this yeah he absolutely knows what's
going on Sean and the reason I know that
is because we've had whistleblowers from
Facebook come and testify under oath
that they collected that kind of
information I just shared with you and
sent it to Zucker personally and he
ignored it I mean so what he should have
said to the families is I'm so sorry for
what we've done and we will do better
and the way they're going to do better
is they'll hold themselves accountable
listen Mark Zuckerberg's worth
$140
billion if he devoted just 10% of that
to helping victims think what it could
do for these families and by the way if
he would actually change his platform
and not allow pedophiles and and sex
Predators on there he could do a service
to every family in America I'll just say
this Sean he seems to have all the time
and attention in the world to censor
conservatives Facebook leapt at the
opportunity to censor any questions
about covid to label people who had
covid vaccine questions as uh as as
potential terrorists if you question the
hunter Biden laptop they shut you down
but yet they can't lift a finger to take
sex Predators off their platform I don't
buy it yeah there's a lawsuit Senator
Graham who said that Zuckerberg has
blood on his hands and he referenced the
South Carol Ina State Rep uh who was
suing Instagram after a 17-year-old son
Gavin died by suicide after falling
victim to an extortion group from
Nigeria operating through a meta owned
app they threatened the young man that
if you don't give them the money that
they would expose photos that I guess
they they kind of manipulated this kid
into sending how common is this so
parents really need to understand how
common is this your kids are on social
media you know all their friends are on
social media okay but these things there
are predators out there that are doing
these things to children and they think
there's no way out like in this case
except to you know obviously this kid
saw no other way out he felt the real
pressure of a an
extortion well get this Sean just three
years ago the the center for exploited
and missing children that keeps track of
these statistics reported only about a
100 cases of of that kind of sextortion
it's called last year they reported over
20,000 of these cases online 20,000 I
mean as a as a father that strikes fear
into my heart I know it does in the
heart of every parent that's out there
here's another statistic the New Mexico
attorney general didn't investigation
they found that a profile of a
13-year-old girl it was only up for a
day on Instagram before she had been
added against her will to a a a group a
chat group that included pedophiles and
other people who were propositioning her
for sex 13 years old was her profile I
mean this stuff it's outrageous
Zuckerberg knows about it he needs to be
accountable for it and they need to pay
for it and by the way where's the FBI I
know they're busy investigating moms and
dads showing up at school board meetings
as uh domestic terrorists and I know
they're busy going after peaceful
protesters uh that are pro-life uh and I
know they're busy uh warning big Tech
about uh a potential disinformation
campaign that might have to do with
Hunter and Joe Biden which I believe
played a part in the 2020 election um
you know at what point do they get held
accountable they have they have
protections that other news
organizations don't have because they're
supposed to be a platform but at what
point does the responsibility lie with
them to make sure that children on these
sites are fully
protected well number one the the
responsibility should lie with the sites
right now with the platforms these are
the biggest richest companies in the
world there's no reason they should be
getting handouts from government in the
form of special protections you should
be able to sue them if your if your kid
gets propositioned online if your kid
gets sex abuse material child porn
pushed to him online you ought to be
able to stop that as a mom or dad
including by suing them number one
number two as to the FBI you know here's
what the FBI was talking to Facebook
about they were pressuring Facebook to
take down posts about Hunter Biden they
were pressuring Facebook to take down
posts about the covid vaccine posts
about election in inte that's where all
their focus has been they're not focused
on sex Predators they're focused on
suppressing speech they've got it
exactly backwards Sean they need to be
held accountable to and that starts with
Chris Ray he's got to go Mark Zuckerberg
he should be on the hook personally it's
time to get these people actually
focused on working for us being
responsible doing the right thing it's
sad these stories about what's happening
to young kids is mind-blowing Senator
great job today uh let's see if anything
happens with that apology and what
they're doing moving forward we
appreciate you being with us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else